Nigel great to have you back good to be
in person
uh you're going to make me wear
Wisconsin Badger gear here as I root for
you guys to Mona definitely thing as a
punishment you know it's really not a
punishment to where was cause how would
I get it right man can you and you're
not a true badger fan I think you've had
a change of heart so for that you know
but I wore a Buckeye as I am to who I
can't be a Buckeye anymore
I know but I I'm a Buckeye are you you
know my mother's a Buckeye fan yeah well
I don't Roo know I I grew up rooting for
Ohio football yep right there in the
same boat yeah how close were you did
Ohio State on for your scholarship they
did they did they were my final two
between obviously Wisconsin and Ohio and
Wisconsin paid better but so that's why
wait is that that's not true right yeah
no no not you is not true at all not
true at all and and by the way I'm
looking at the gear I mean there's red
that's not it's scarlet and gray with
Ohio State I actually don't know what
these colors are you don't there's
always a fancy name it's never just red
and white there's always a fancier about
name for the color okay so I'll get back
to you on that okay but since you were
talking about me giving signing shoes
because I have Kobe shoes so I signed oh
they're my shoes
awesome and it says to my favorite
badger fan so these are for you
so hopefully they can well sit somewhere
here well maybe next to the ollie sure
are yeah I sit behind the shrine so you
can't I leave you nor these game-worn
of course they are vintage looking more
and look at that lots of windows right
there Bailey yeah
and also for you to watch the game we
have you a badger scarf Wow
well we expect to see photos throughout
the Twittersphere my manager yeah you
look good I drew sweater on you like
this the Kate I do look good
professor yeah you look good yeah you
look good yeah well thank you for the
gifts there no problem a couple things I
wanted to ask you about now of course
you you hit the game-winning shot
against Villanova you know and we talked
about the whole process of getting the
ball in a moment
but not really thinking about what
you're going to do with the ball when
you get the ball in a moment like that
like that I guess that's how athletes
are you it's reactionary but there was
no thought process to that their coach
doesn't say clear out let you do what
you need to do it's just you saying all
right let me survey the situation and
then make something of it it's kind of
the play was drawn up to give me the
ball I slayed it on that wing area so I
used to go to my strong hand and yeah no
I didn't have anything thought-out to do
because that kind of put you in the best
spots one of the things that actually
tell you to do the least amount when
you're playing a game with the thing
because the more you think you're having
to make bad decisions but before that I
kind of was you know enjoying the
surreal mists of the the whole ordeal
kind of thinking I'm out of bounds like
my heart's beating sighs I could really
felt my heart beating I'm tonight wow
it's a big moment right now you know I
look back I see my mother she's cheering
crazily as she always is love her to
death
hi mom and I'm thinking well I need to I
need to score baskets we need to win
this game so I caught the ball then it
went blank from catching it to scoring
it and then at the end I'm like okay I
made it now we need to get a stop so
it's kind of them can you hear your mom
during again always everyone does we'll
go to a timeout and you're I hear
screaming are one of our favorite lines
is let's go babies so when she sees when
she yells that everyone goes up Nigel's
mom's here yeah it's crazy because all
those people there all the screaming and
I can still not only myself but everyone
else can still distinctly hear best
player you faced in college in your
career pursue in college oh is either
Adrian Payne or DJ Newbill from Penn
State or Michigan State and Penn State
respectively those guys were it was
pretty good guys they were definitely
really good at basketball even outside
so nobody outside the big tent um
outside the Big Ten who do you have who
Patra someone I mean you've been around
for a little while here annoying I have
I've been there for years yeah we
definitely played against some good guys
but I think those were two guys were um
Oh Joe young from Oregon yeah he was he
was really good as well those are the
three guys kind of collectively I'm
amongst a team we were like yeah those
guys are really good
and there's nothing that we could do to
stop them from scoring the ball what do
you think of the one in general
obviously you stayed for four years but
the one and done rule and what it's
doing for college basketball and what
it's doing for the NBA um I mean I think
the I think the player should be allowed
to decide if they want to do but I think
it's a good rule in the sense that you
can mature a little bit what I did I'm
feeling done or go out out of high
school um I would say go out of high
school because I think a lot of it
depends on lot of the kids want to get
there because unfortunately they come
from bad situations home but if I gave
you the option if you went to college
you had to stay two years if you want to
come out of high school and you want to
go right to the pros and try then you
should be able to I mean the right to
work I'm fine with that
uh-huh because in other sports we don't
look at this the same way we do
basketball so we're not even we're not
being fair to basketball players but I'm
trying to figure what's going to be good
so we don't make a mockery of college
basketball if you're one and done
chances are you're not going to school
second semester right chances are yeah
chances are you probably not yeah um I
mean I I personally think that it should
be less is one of done I think it's
really good it gives them at least a
semester and maybe a little bit more to
maybe meet someone that could help them
with their lives because a lot of the
problems you see when kids get to the
NBA they say you know they're they're
not ready they're not mature enough they
don't know this they don't know that and
I've managed money yeah and I think you
know that semester they're there
hopefully before they go off the train
you know maybe someone could say
something to them they can meet the
right person um and if they do say great
um you know but why did you stay four
years I wasn't good enough to go yet you
don't think you could go last year I
think I could have went last year I
don't know I thought it'd have been the
best decision for me I think I
definitely could come back not only get
better in basketball also mature as a
basketball player learn more about the
game develop better leadership skills um
when a couple championships I'm trying
to I could graduate get how important to
look that degree extremely important
it's more important anything I can do
come on that's per my mother so he
that's what he cares about the most no
matter what Awards I get about how many
championships I want I was going to ask
you about you know the the student
athlete if I paid let's say you were
paid minimum wage for the 20 hours let's
say minimum wage 20 hours a week what
athletes look at that and say okay not
now now there's something here do you
would you sign up for that um 10 bucks
an hour 20 hours a week um oh is that
that removing anything or that we got me
on job on top yeah I mean I think that's
definitely a start a good start it would
be a good way to go um I'm not I
probably need to you know maybe sit down
think about some more maybe crunch some
numbers yeah i'ma find a finance guy you
know Finance writer I can't just agree
to anything in the air like that si get
yourself in trouble that you've spoken
about student-athletes and yeah you know
you held up a sign that you know you
guys are on for hug the Sun oh gosh
thanks no but I doubt the fact that
you're you you're thinking outside of
just being a basketball player right you
know education is important you're
thinking bigger picture here again and I
love the approach I'm sure there are a
lot of people criticize that but I
viewed it as you could have just gone
about your regular life in college and
play basketball but you're thinking
differently and I and I like that well I
think you're not afraid I'm doing my
best to shine try and give that okay but
what do you do if I gave you the
opportunity to run in the NCAA you draw
it up arm I think it best to be remove
the not paying athletes I think you
should be allowed the universities to
compensate their athletes how they feel
and I think given that a lot of
universities would take especially the
coach I've know coaches and athletic
directors they agree that players should
be paid they don't say it publicly
because they want to avoid the criticism
that you know I'm receiving for saying
this but I think that they would
definitely give the players more because
they know some of the things that
players have to go to it's not
necessarily agreed that the players want
money it's when they're one to do
something that they're unable to do so
for instance I wanted to see my mother
for Thanksgiving freshman year but I
couldn't get home I couldn't afford a
plane ticket so I think if we were
compensated for the
the millions and billions we hope the
n-c-double-a hue words generate how much
am i worth I don't know it's funny there
was a tweet once that we that we had
Zach Bohannon put it in our team group
chat and I think I was I was third and
college players a month of money
receives and it was in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars so I don't know if
that's going up or down but uh how much
am i worth I don't know say there's no
price I'm priceless
oh you are yeah but we got a price tag
on oh you got to put a price tag on um I
don't I don't know I think that was
that's where the people with the pH D's
come in you know I'm still an undergrad
mmm right now
so uh I haven't really you're not going
to stay another year right no you're
finally leaving Wisconsin finally after
seven years funny though everyone talks
about me been there that long it means
one thing I've done something all my
four years but I'm gonna get credit for
a year and a half like there be guys at
Duke or North Carolina it felt like they
were there forever because if we start
to see you we've seen you since your
freshman year Yeah right look is good
yeah I've been a contributor yeah
although it feels like you've been there
a long long time it does and you're the
27 28 years of age - right I'm only 22
that's still crazy show he's been here
five years he's older than me and no one
ever mentions how old show his own butt
how much time did you give to your hair
Holly bases not nearly enough is what
you think it's not it it's kind of
natural people always ask me how do I
get my hair like that you know just the
magic of being black is it kind of it
did it on its own and now you know I
just breathe the benefits of the
luscious Drake classless that I have you
know so there's really no magic formula
behind it besides hmm you know just be a
chocolate looks good
ah stop it looks good thank you good
luck don't screw up again still Florida
well I can't not what you wearing the
good luck scarf I believe me I'll have a
gator sweater or you'll all have that on
own you got governor are you guys gonna
let that happen
go say no you're gonna want to happen in
Florida wins all of a sudden I got a
gator scarf on it's up to you okay I'll
do my best all right all right
Nigel Hayes to my badgers
Florida coming up tomorrow night the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience